ok ya llenes tu cerebro con un montón de
derivadas parciales de sí respecto de x
de y creo que ahora es el momento de
hacerlo en realidad con una ecuación
diferencial concreta y hacer esto más
claro así que vamos a decir que tengo
la ecuación diferencial por coseno de x
ok más 2 veces x a la aie
y qué más le hacemos más seno de equis
ok seno de x mas x al cuadrado por ea la
y menos 1 y esto último multiplicando a
la derivada de ye respecto de x y esto
lo igualamos a 0 ok entonces esperemos
ya estemos en el modo adecuado para
poder resolver esto con una ecuación
exacta y ahora lo que hay que observar
de esta parte es que este primer término
es una función que depende de xy de y lo
mismo pasa para esta segunda parte ok
podríamos intentar hacerlo por
separación de variables pero lleva mucho
tiempo darse cuenta que esto no es
posible así que si no es por separación
de variables pues vamos a intentar si es
una ecuación exacta así que ésta
procuraremos que sea nuestra función m
de xy y está nuestra función ndx ok
ahora la prueba para ver si esto es una
ecuación exacta
es derivar la función m respecto de iu y
ver que sea igual a la derivada de n
respecto de x ok
quien es la derivada de m respecto de y
bueno pues esto simplemente será coseno
dx más la 2x es una constante para fines
de derivar respecto de iu y sólo nos
queda 2x por la derivada de alaye que es
2x por ea la y muy bien ahora como es la
derivada de n respecto de x bueno si
derivamos n tenemos que la derivada de
seno simplemente es coseno de x correcto
entonces el primer término es fácil es
coseno de x y luego a la ye es una
constante para fines de derivar respecto
de x y la derivada de x cuadrada es 2x y
multiplicamos por el iedt y luego la
derivada de una constante simplemente 0
ok
entonces ahora ya tenemos las derivadas
de m respecto de ella y n respecto de x
y lo que aquí observamos es que es
exactamente igual estas dos expresiones
así que ya está hemos demostrado que m
su pie es igual a n sub x lo cual nos
dice inmediatamente que esta ecuación es
exacta ok
esta expresión o más bien esta igualdad
de expresiones nos dice que esta
ecuación es exacta así que mi esposa
acaba de colarse detrás de mí y pensé
que había algún criterio en casa o algo
así es bueno de todos modos que nos dice
bueno eso nos dice que hay alguna
función sí que depende de xy de y tal
que la derivada respecto de x ccm y su
derivada respecto de y es igual a n si
sabemos cuál es sí entonces podemos
reescribir esta ecuación diferencial
como la derivada
si respecto de x0 ok vamos a resolver
para sí ya que sabemos que la derivada
respecto de x depp si es m
entonces escribimos la parcial de epsy
respecto de x es igual a m que en este
caso es que por coseno de x más 2 x port
y alaia
está justo aquí arriba podríamos haber
hecho al revés haber empezado con la
parcial de eps y respecto de iu y poner
la función n pero vamos a hacerlo por el
momento con x ahora vamos a obtener una
primera aproximación de lo que bueno una
aproximación sino lo que vamos a tomar
es una deriva perdón no tampoco es una
derivada es vamos a tomar la primitiva
de ambos lados es decir vamos a integrar
de este lado izquierdo respecto de x ok
y del otro lado también ok al integrar
respecto de x
sub x esto va a ser igual vamos a
integrar respecto de x por supuesto y
esto va a ser igual a la integral de
todo esto que es x coseno de x más 2 x x
ala y respecto de x ok
estamos integrando respecto de x ahora
normalmente al integrar esto respecto de
x decimos bueno al final me queda una
constante pero notemos que también una
constante para fines de integral
respecto de x puede ser cualquier
función que dependa de ella como una
constante cierto y bueno esto tiene
sentido verdad porque si tomáramos la
parcial respecto de x de esta expresión
bueno si aquí tenemos una función que
depende explícitamente sólo de y
entonces al derivar respecto de x toda
esta función se anula correcto entonces
de todos modos esto simplificará up sí
porque al integrar su derivada respecto
de x simplemente nos queda si ahora el
detalle será integrar esta expresión
ya después determinaremos quién es esta
función que depende únicamente de ella
así que vamos a averiguar quién es este
integral
vamos a hacerlo en azul y recordemos que
ya es una constante para fines de esta
integral así que de la primera tenemos
que es el seno de x más si integramos
todo esto simplemente nos queda la
integral de 2x que es x cuadrada que
multiplica a la ye
entonces solo falta agregar esta función
efe y entonces ya tenemos esta expresión
previa o preliminar de lo que es si si
tomamos la parcial de esto respecto de x
vamos a encontrar el integrando cierto
que en este caso es m ahora a
continuación vamos a ver qué pasa con f
de y estamos ya casi a nada de encontrar
la solución casi hemos averiguado quién
es si excepto por esta función bella
ahora bien sabemos que si tomamos la
derivada respecto de y debemos encontrar
nuestra función n así que vamos a hacer
esto vamos a derivar si la parcial de
pepsi respecto de y muy bien
la parcial de pge y respecto de ella
aquí x es una constante entonces
simplemente al derivar este término nos
queda seno de x ahora sumamos la
derivada de este término respecto del x
cuadrada es constante y sólo derivamos
al ayer que es el ayer y finalmente
derivamos efe de respecto de y que es
simplemente f prima de i
ahora que hicimos tomamos m integramos
respecto a xy nos dice muy bien
podríamos haber perdido mucha
información pero realmente ya tenemos
resuelta esta integral y hemos
construido todas y de esta forma
simplemente vamos a determinar f prima
de y eso lo haremos igualando esta
expresión con nuestra función n
entonces esto vimos que n
déjenme encontrarlo acá está en el seno
de x x cuadrada por el al menos 1
entonces esto es seno de x
y que era que era así más más x cuadrada
por al menos 1
eso fue nuestra n original de la
ecuación diferencial ahora resolvamos
para f prima de y vamos a ver qué se
repite en varios términos dejen
escribirlo de nuevo seno de x mas x
cuadrada a la ye más efe prima de y
igual a de este lado tenemos seno de x
mas x cuadrada por ea la ye menos 1 y
entonces vemos que este seno de x se
cancela con este seno de x x cuadra por
ea la ye con esta x cuadrada korea la ye
y simplemente nos queda una ecuación
diferencial de esta forma la derivada de
f respecto de ella es igual a 1 así que
ahora sólo encontraremos efe resolviendo
esta ecuación diferencial que es muy
sencilla así que si su derivada es 1 así
que esta es nuestra nuestra función
efe y podemos agregar cualquier
constante c
ahora si sustituimos esto cuál sería
entonces nuestra si bueno
de xy
era igual a esta parte que teníamos acá
arriba y seno de x seno seno de x ok
más más x cuadrada por ella la y más
ahora esta función que más se espera en
la derivada era menos 1 así que aquí
sería menos
disculpen disculpen este error bueno
sustituyendo esto es menos yemas y
entonces que nos dice bien dijimos que
la ecuación diferencial de arriba la
original usando la regla de la cadena
para para usando derivadas parciales
podemos reescribir la de la siguiente
forma que la derivada total de sí
respecto de x era bueno ésta depende de
xy de y esto es igual a cero o bien si
fuéramos a integrar de ambos lados
respecto de x tendríamos que si de xy es
igual a una constante
es igual a una constante correcto
entonces si ya obtuvimos sí entonces
simplemente lo sustituimos es decir que
por el seno de x mas x cuadrada por ea
la ye menos y menos ye más una constante
déjenme llamarle ésta hace 1 es igual a
otra constante s 2 bien podrían ser las
mismas distintas vamos a quedarnos sólo
con una constante del lado derecho que
es restando las recapitulemos obtuvimos
que esta ecuación diferencial era exacta
porque porque derivamos esta m respecto
de iu y vimos que era igual a esta n al
derivar la respecto de x como vimos que
eran iguales dijimos ok entonces si es
exacta vamos a averiguar cuál es la pge
y que necesitamos para resolver el
problema entonces si su derivada parcial
respecto de x era igual a m por lo cual
si integrábamos si integramos esto
respecto de x y vamos a obtener la
expresión de pepsi excepto por una
función que depende exclusivamente de
ella
ok ahora tomábamos que si deriva vamos
la función si respecto de y esto nos
tenía que dar igual a n y la f se deriva
entonces nos queda al final una ecuación
diferencial que deberíamos resolver pero
para nuestra función
efe al resolver la obtuvimos nuestra app
si final y entonces la ecuación
diferencial debido a la regla de la
cadena utilizando derivadas parciales la
re escribíamos como si de xy igual a una
constante nos vemos en el próximo vídeo